Build It.
Draw It.
Play It.
Vsauce!
This is your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people.
This is BiDiPi.
BUILD IT
Olek is a Polish-born Yarn artist living in
New York City that creates massive crocheted
installations like covering this train.
It took two days and four assistants to complete
and is on display in Lodz, Poland.
She's done several great installations with
yarn including The End is Far, The Animal
Ball and the Crocheted Rickshaw.
Sunset skateboard company makes LED-lighted
boards that last up to 100,000 hours.
No batteries are required because the lights
are powered by the motion of the wheels.
They give you the option to pick one of their
designs like the Ghost or the Wave or just
build your own.
Artist Brian Dettmer made these awesome skeleton
sculptures from melted cassette tapes including
a bird, elk and bull skulls.
He also made these human skulls named after
the tapes used to make them such 80's metal,
and women of pop.
He has many more amazing sculptures so be
sure to check out his website for more.
The Archibird Cage Table was created by French
designer Gregoire De Lafforest.
And the main part of the cage is attached
underneath the table and clear viewing tubes
protrude though the top giving the birds the
ability to fly up into them and become part
of the tabletop decoration.
DRAW IT
Dirty Little Secrets is an art series by Sara
Rosado using dirt from local parks as a medium.
Some of her dirty little secrets include Lonely
Panda, Ants, New York Skyline, and a Cat.
Coiffure le Bird is a photo series by photographer
Rene Mesman.
Using both a hairstylist and an art director
the series includes san owl, crow, and a falcon.
And now for "The Pinks" a masculine figures
in pink series done by Scott Scheildy
1,000 shadows is an ongoing street art series
by artist Herbert Baglione.
In this set he used an abandoned psychiatric
hospital in Italy to showcase some of his
haunting silhouette paintings.
Play it
Alfieproducer plays 42 current pop songs arranged
himself, in a row, in one take, without any
editing.
Impression Rhapsody is Paul Vlahos' version
of Bohemian Rhapsody done in a plethora of
famous voices
The fantastic CDZA does Justin Genrelake which
is a cover of Justin Timberlake's "My Love"
in 13 different genres
Finally, here is Vivaldi Tribute played by
14 year old Tina, and it's awesome.
Submit your BiDiPis as a personal message
here on YouTube.
Or share them with everyone over at Facebook.com/VsauceTwo.
Click here to listen to a brand new installment
of BiDiPi Radio.
Music created and submitted by you guys.
Also check out Your BiDiPi - an entire video
dedicated to your creations.
And as always - thanks for watching.